j'accueille mariage droite
une amie marie noëlle lienemann franck
dubosc david hallyday voilà donc il y en
a près jubilation vers le ciel après les
cimetières sont des champs de fleurs
après anissa corto vous publiez votre
quatrième roman qui s'appelle podium
alors pour la sortie de 1 à nice à corto
vous aviez fait passer une annonce janne
dans la presse avec appelle moi et mes
os x 20 watts sans appel moix avec votre
numéro de portable alors résultat
beaucoup de lecteurs de têtu le fameux
magazine gay vous en téléphoné il ya une
fille quand même qui vous a téléphoné en
me levant j'ai envie de toi est vite et
vous avez compris quelques jours plus
tard que c'était trois copains du figaro
en fait que vous avez fait une sale
blague
est-ce que ce soir vous êtes prêts à
recommencer à donner à l'antenne votre
numéro de portable
yann moix 06 62 37 61 60
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un petit
replay sert s'il te plaît
06 62 37 61 60 euros d'olivia bonamy
achever de noter alors bien alors on
arrive à la question désormais chaque
semaine dans cette émission il y aura
une question qui s'appelle la question
alors quelques semaines j'ai hésité
entre la question trop con pour que je
vous la pose moi même et la question de
claire chazal et finalement j'ai choisi
la question de claire chazal
attention vous êtes prêt yann moix
attention est ce qu'on peut dire yann
moix que podium et le roman de la
rentrée allait oui je crois que c'est le
moment de la rentrée
ouais en fait je suis ton beaucoup trop
modeste pour me comparer aux écrivains
français est mort non si je me compare
aux écrivains français vivent peut
effectivement dire que c'est le roman la
rentrée et ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que c'est bizarre parce que c'est un
roman sur les saisies coûteront serait
claude françois alors si bizarre c'est
moi qui parle des yéyés et s'il est
vraiment la rentrée qui sont vieux de 30
ans à côté ouais bien joie que j'ai
préparé vos formules pour les ans vous
allez faire c'est bien vous avez regardé
le show pendant les vacances
en tous les cas vous êtes sur la liste
du goncourt maintenant le tout c'est d'y
rester le plus longtemps possible
c'est un peu comme un cheval de rodéo
oui c'est comme un jeu un peu télé ou
faut pas tomber
oui vous n'êtes pas très souriant vous
n'êtes jamais très souriant et j'ai
appris en lisant paris match que quand
vous étiez petit on vous avait mis des
bagues sur les dents on nous appelait
d'ailleurs la banane metalik ce custom
un surnom heavy metal centrales
nucléaires
c'est ses plaisanteries je n'avais plus
le comme vous avez pu le faire nous
avait le masque si je souris toujours
mais par les yeux par les oreilles par
les cheveux par les mains puis j'arrive
plus à sourire par la bouche ce qui est
un peu paradoxale
voilà je serai d'une force et ça se voit
si rené broca faiblard ne vont pas
toujours
je peux pas y arriver moi je peux pas
moi c'est pas pareil quand un animateur
télé ces mêmes blues qui empoigne et
regarder sabatier vous l'avez ça aussi
vous voulez les ac après tout vous avez
déjà vu ça allait les bacs sur le
journal le casque
ah ouais ah oui le 15 mai au pas le cas
d'ivan espèce de casque hi-fi et les
dents et un jour j'avais ça je dormais
avec une amie n'est pas en france a dit
patrick ou de temps aux communes en fait
il fait un truc c'était terrible alors
on va passer un podium yann le pitch de
podium c'est l'histoire d'un sosie de
claude françois effectivement qui
s'appelle bernard frédéric et puis il a
un copain qui s'appelle jean baptiste
cousseau dit couscous qui est le
narrateur lui c'est un ex sosie de
claude françois mais il est recyclé en
sosie de c'est géraud nom de d jérôme ce
qui vient après lui bien entendu le
livre est très très drôle
alors ce bernard frédéric basse et un
sosie dissidents non agréé par le club
officiel de lens ouais mais c'est ça
qu'elle est saisie officielle est saisie
freelance
voilà alors il doit effectivement
refaire tous les concours parce qu'il
veut participer à l'émission d'evelyne
thomas que nous saluons ici c'est mon
choix
voilà un et donc été obligé de retourner
un petit peu à l'école des sosies de
passer des concours
les titres de chaque chapitre sont des
chansons de claude françois
c'est un bel exercice exact il ya même
une chanson qui s'appelle hip hip hip
hourra qu'il a une chanson de gainsbourg
qu'il avait enregistré en 67 et
lorsqu'elle plus drôle c'est les entrées
de chapitres toutes ses phrases que vous
que vous relevez de la bouche des sosies
il y en a un qui dit j'ai effacé bernard
frédéric qui dit j'ai toute la vie de
claude françois devant moi et d'ailleurs
j'ai voulu qu'elle se livre à cause de
deux phrases comme on dit les saisies
claude françois et qui j'avais déjeuné
et la phrase qui a tout déclenché c'est
un sosie qui apprennent pas à m'avoir
parlé de claude françois pendant une
heure et demie me dit tu sais gagnent je
suis beaucoup mieux dans ma peau depuis
que dans celle de claude il ya un autre
un autre déjeuner me parle pendant une
heure et demie et à la fin du déjeuner
me dit cette phrase démente et là je me
suis décidé à écrire le roman il me dit
s'y prête à un taux de françois comme
les autres c'est pas la peine
j'avais mon sujet et mène ici c'est le
françois et et claude françois
dès sa naissance mois il a fallu que je
travaille comme un malade pour rattraper
mon retard
iliad est vraiment des perles et puis
pendant le concours aussi font donc le
concours vont participer pour devenir un
vrai sosie pour participer à l'émission
d'evelyne thomas et il dit le prof dit
c'est pas parce que vous êtes des sosies
qu'il faut copier mise en examen comme
le bac vous voilà enfin qu'ils disent
que je préfère en moi c'est claude et
depuis j'en ai eu notre fabuleuse qu'on
a bien saisi mais je peux plus
l'intégrer dans le roman et c'est trop
l'émission mois claude françois serait
resté claude françois et nous aidiez à
ce moment là j'ai compris que je tenais
non seulement un sujet de roman mais un
thème universel finalement thèmes
universels d'autant que aujourd'hui on
est dans la terrorisme de la célébrité
en attendant la démocratisation de la
delà de la star et de la célébrité mais
c'est ça c'est vachement intéressant de
comprendre qu'on est dans une époque où
la notoriété précède l'oeuvre et même
parfois la remplace c'est à dire
qu'avant on faisait une oeuvre une
chanson un livre et on devenait
éventuellement célèbre aujourd'hui on
est célèbre d'abord et on regarde ce
qu'on fait c'est vrai il faut remplir la
notoriété dans la chose oui on a un vase
qui s'appelle la célébrité on regarde ce
qu'on peut mettre dedans et si ça
continue comme ça c'est les inconnues
qui vont devenir parfaitement célèbre
mêmes on dira donc n'est pas inconnu toi
il y aura dans les boîtes de nuit des
vip very important people se réuniront
dans des carrés à cet effet alors que
les gens qui ne sont pas passés à la
télé il y en aura plus que cinq ou six
plus vous citez souvent l'exemple david
du loft qui dit moins célèbres c'est ce
que j'ai toujours voulu faire et non va
être non c'est à dire que le fer et le
lettres se sont venus connexes et la
célébrité l'anonymat sont devenus
synonymes
je sais par exemple depuis deux ans en
regardant les couvertures de ty télé 7
jours
un qu'ils ont des stars ouverture sept
jours parce que je ne les connais pas et
comme sont des anonymes je sais que
c'est des gens connus c'est vrai tout ça
se passe dans un univers très france
d'en bas de shopi shop de bricorama sans
mépris derrière de bach
j'ai pas mépriser l'endroit où j'ai
habité pendant 20 ans ouais sert près
d'orléans jetterait province on
travaille bien que sur ce qu'on connaît
ouais
après tout faut que mr ne travailler que
sur quelques mètres carrés avec un champ
de maïs une grange et puis un fleuve pas
loin puis ça suffit pour faire un roman
c'est même trop mais c'est vrai que
depuis houellebecq à un tendance comme
ça à regarder la réalité dans les romans
où je crois que la définition qu'on peut
donner un écrivain c'est quelqu'un qui
nous parle du monde dans lequel on vit
actuellement
si c'est pour faire des livres qui
aurait pu se passer en 1936 c'est pas
tellement intéressant en fait
enfin tous les cas c'est un livre plutôt
bien ficelé une rentrée bien orchestré
les médias se sont fait l'écho qu'elle
le dit c'est le cas de le dire oui tout
va très bien mais il ya un problème
lequel vous savez bien car je savais
qu'il y aurait un problème là elle a eu
lien pour le du jura probable il ya
manifestement vous mettez les homos à
dos et oui et oui le personnage bien sûr
vous dis que c'est pas moi c'est le
personnage mais sa légende têtu ne sont
pas dus et il vous en veulent c'est vrai
que ce personnage très sans anthony est
ce que s'en prend violemment aux
homosexuels vous avez dû pour parce que
les phrases qui ont été relevés par le
magazine têtu ne sont pas les pires non
non rien à bien pire
en fait je pars du principe que je n'ai
pas aimé les homosexuels et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi si pour moi les
homosexuels n'existe pas exactement
comme les hétérosexuels n'existe pas je
considère qu'à une sexualité par
personne que la communauté homosexuelle
c'est quelque chose qui m'échappe comme
si par exemple on a une communauté des
mecs à lunettes blond avec des doubles
foyer qui mettent des baskets adidas
je trouve que pourquoi non mais c'est
vrai c'est très étrange
ce serait drôle enfermé
il accuse les temps 19 ans je trouve que
la sexualité quelque chose tellement
individuel que je pense que parfois il
ya moins de différences entre un
hétérosexuel et un homosexuel qui entre
deux homosexuels est donc tout
simplement il ya des individus qui
m'intéresse et comme il ya une sexualité
par individu j'ai pas à dire j'aime les
homosexuels cette phrase ne fait pas
sens chez moi exactement comme la phrase
j'aime ou j'aime pas les hétérosexuels
fait pas sens où les bisexuels les dans
la rome antique
on sait même pas si distinction il n'y
avait que la sexualité quelque chose
d'individuel vous êtes cuir verni cuir
sans le savoir elle a du bon mais il ya
quand même des phrases terribles vous
dites je ne suis pas homosexuel j'ai pas
un cancer du slip comme classe naomi je
recrute sun page thierry le luron pas
georges et lire ça dans les romans
français personnages à peine le sida et
un cancer du slip parce qu'il parle de
manière très imagée et que je me suis
amusé en fait essayer de trouver un
langage neuf langues pour ce personnage
dans les romans burlesque
en fait on fait souvent ça et pour
trouver s'engage j'ai croisé le roman de
renart et les interviews de jean claude
van damme et ça donne ça on le connaît
bien ici jean claude van damme
ça m'amuse la maison du québec et à
romain non
n'y avait pas à vous les pédales on peux
vraiment pas vous sentir déjà que dans
les hôpitaux on poireaute des plombes à
cause de vos filles ont infecté c'est
beaucoup mais attendez je précise quand
même que c'est mon personnage qui parle
et je laissais j'ai essayé de faire un
personnage antipathique
non je crois que j'y suis arrivé et le
mec le mec est radin dire qu'il va il
passe sa vie dans les restaurants à
volonté par exemple 25 fois une demande
des suppléments viande jusqu'à temps
qu'ils oeuvrent actuellement tout ce qui
est gratuit les preneurs nous et puis en
même temps je vais le rendre encore plus
antipathique donc en plus ils homophobes
a été réussie d'air que l'homophobie la
radinerie sont parmi les défauts les
pires que puisse avoir un être humain
voilà j'en ai fait un personnage moi en
tous les cas c'est un roman très drôle
très picaresque un peu amphigourique de
temps en temps oui non c'est le deuxième
problème de la soirée ça c'est un
problème pour moi pour le bouquin non
c'est très bien et j'espère est-ce que
des sosies de johnny hallyday beaucoup
non oui je connais ainsi johnny hallyday
qui m'a dit une phrase inoubliable il
m'a dit je suis bien content que johnny
se soit stabilisée senti mentalement
parce que j'arrive plus à suivre
j'ai cherché j'ai trouvé des photos d'un
sosie de david mais franchement je vais
pas invité ce soir parce que il est
beaucoup moins bon vous vous
reconnaissez votre saisie non non pas du
tout non parce que michel sardou il
connaît son sosie à elle est plein de
problèmes avec son sosie de nommer car
du serge cardu ouais ok en tôle avant
une enquête le scoop vous connaissez pas
le vote de la prochaine fois je
l'inviterai oui avec peu de m'avoir
invité et je pense que franck dubosc
viendra dans une autre émission pour
parler la byblos bank dubosc en tous les
cas vous montrer une érudition
extraordinaire sur claude françois vous
avez eu beaucoup tous les tous les
podiums qui était son journal et le
titre de voter tous les madmoizelles
achetant de salut les copains le
meilleur pour ce livre j'ai lu la bible
intégralement ce que j'avais mais jamais
fait don quichotte et tous les numéros
deux podiums et tout livre j'ai trouvé
sur claude françois ouais j'ai fait un
mixage de tout ça ça donne un livre
oui parce qu'on apprend beaucoup de
choses sur claude françois en même temps
je dirais est d'abord vous tordez le cou
à cette rumeur sur la mort de claude
françois on dit toujours la star a été
électrocuté par un godemiché dans son
bain vibromasseur d'y vivre au mas alors
j'ai enquêté effectivement dans ce livre
il ya la déception la mort de claude
françois seconde par seconde et un jour
je me suis dit bon 7 tests viraux
minceur qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir
faire pour lui la guillotine est et j'ai
une idée toute bête chez les avants rue
saint denis dans un sex-shop et sans
parler de claude françois je suis arrivé
j'ai dit un type voilà et je voudrais
offrir un vibromasseur à ma copine mais
j'ai peur qu'ils aient des problèmes
parce qu'elles puissent électrocuté
autres il y va du tout les 10 au 20
heures ça marche pas sur secteur ça
marche à piles les batailles et une
légende s'évapore en quelques secondes
voilà c'est simple que ça alors il est
mort comment claude françois c'est un
obsessionnel un maniaque un dingue et il
ne pouvait pas supporter par exemple que
sur son bureau le client de papier soit
pas parallèles à l'angle du bureau et si
tu es toujours comme ça et donc kevin
ampoules qu'il narguait depuis des
semaines et un jour il s'est dit bon
c'est elle ou moi ça peut plus durer
soit elle fait un effort elle serait qui
fit d'elle même soit je vais être
obligée de me lever et le faire moi même
et ça il supportait pas les rapports de
comme il avait les pieds dans l'eau il a
pris le courant voilà alors il s'est
levé et il a reçu la lumière puisqu'un
livre christie qui ont une taurus c'est
vrai